jetzt ist es raus neue impfkampagne neue
maßnahmen neues datenchaos der pandemie
herbst er kommt und in jedem fall was
die maßnahmen angeht können wir uns auf
einiges einstellen denn die
bundesregierung hat einen geheimen
corona plan aufgestellt und in einer
corona konferenz bereits festgelegt im
kanzleramt stellte der kanzleramtschef
wolfgang schmidt den chefs der
staatskanzleien den regierungsplan für
den kommenden herbst vor ein gehege neue
impfkampagne mit neuen angepassten
impfstoffen die unterschiedlich lang
halten und auch das daten chaos könnte
damit zurückkommen was steckt alles
dahinter das weiß bild meinungs- schiffe
philippiak of und dem begrüßen aids im
studio schön dass du da bist philipp ein
geheimes treffen im kanzleramt was ist
dabei herausgekommen
ja das war eine schaltkonferenz
organisiert vom kanzleramt und daran
nahm kanzleramtschef wolfgang schmidt
teil daran nahmen andere
regierungsvertreter teil und die chefs
der staatskanzleien der länder das fand
bereits am donnerstag vergangener woche
statt es ging um das thema gas aber eben
auch um corona und cola ist ja gerade so
ein bisschen im schatten der anderen
krisen aber man weiß natürlich dass
corona im herbst wieder stärker
zurückkommt und man will darauf
vorbereitet sein und ich glaube das
wichtigste was man sagen kann es die
neue impfkampagne die bundesregierung
will bis zu 60 millionen bundesbürger
erneut impfen das ist eine gewaltige
zahl das heißt im prinzip alle die sich
jetzt schon haben impfen lassen sollten
nach vorstellung der bundesregierung
eine dritte oder vierte impfung bekommen
und da wird das etwas chaotisch weil wir
haben im herbst dann nicht nur
impfstoffe der verschiedenen hersteller
moderner bionic wie wir es kennen
sondern auch noch impfstoffe die in
unterschiedliche corona varianten
angepasst sind also wir haben einerseits
impfstoffe die noch an die sozusagen an
die erste ursprüngliche variante von
corona angepasst sind aber dann auch
welche die an die verschiedenen omikron
varianten angepasst angepasst worden
also baa1 oder br 5 und diese impfstoffe
wirken unterschiedlich gut vor allem
gegen ansteckung das heißt der bürger
steht dann vor der wahl nicht nur nehme
ich jetzt moderner nämlich biontech
sowie es kannte sondern auch noch welche
variante kriege ich eigentlich und was
bedeutet das
das weiß man ja vorher nicht welche
variante man kriegen könnte also die
impfstoffe gerade die allerneusten sind
noch nicht fertig das heißt wir wissen
auch noch nicht genau wann die
ausgeliefert werden wann die wirklich da
sind und es entsteht natürlich ein
gewisses kommunikationschaos weil wie
will man einen bürger beispielsweise 10
für dich ist gerade nicht der
allerneuste impfstoff da das heißt du
bekommst im prinzip nur b-ware natürlich
schützt die und die ist auch genau so
sicher allerdings schützt sie nicht so
gut vor einer ansteckung über
spielsweise die neuesten impfstoffe also
da weiß die bundesregierung auch das
kann ordentlich rocken über maßnahmen
wurde allerdings auch diskutiert ganz
ohne geht es offenbar nicht neben der
masken pflicht den innenräumen soll es
auch noch eins gegen eins geht heißt das
auch kämpfte und ungeimpfte bürger sich
testen lassen müssen bevor sie zu einer
großveranstaltung gehen das alles ist
noch nicht ganz in trockenen tüchern
aber das ist die empfehlung des
sachverständigenrates also dieser
kommission die alle maßnahmen schon
ausgewertet hat und die zu dem schluss
gekommen ist dass das ausschließen von
ungeimpften durch zwei gebe einfach
nicht funktioniert deswegen könnte es
jetzt auf ein g hinaus laufen also
testen testen testen im herbst und
winter
sagte bilden meinung chef philippe
piatti wird also ganz schön kompliziert
im herbst vielen dank